agosto es el mes de la pachamama el mes
en el que se le agradece por los frutos
otorgados es una costumbre que se
practica en bolivia desde épocas
precolombinas este primero de agosto en
ese marco mucha gente se ha dirigido a
las partes altas de las ciudades del
altiplano del país particularmente de la
ciudad de la paz para hacer su ofrenda y
su agradecimiento a la madre tierra esta
ofrenda consiste en prender una fogata y
quemar en ella varias cosas por ejemplo
algunos dulces nueces e incluso fetos
disecados de llamas también a la fogata
se le agrega alcohol y coca y alrededor
la gente pues hace sus pedidos para la
pachamama en ese marco el vicepresidente
del estado david choquehuanca también ha
hecho su ofrenda a la pachamama en esta
jornada en la plaza murillo donde está
el centro del poder político del país de
ese acto ha participado la
vicepresidenta electa de colombia
francia márquez quien se encuentra en
bolivia en el marco de su gira
sudamericana antes de asumir el de su
país por otro lado la alcaldía de la paz
también ha organizado una ofrenda en la
plaza del stadium de la ciudad de la paz
para hacer su agradecimiento a la madre
tierra en el lenguaje popular se dice
que en esta época la madre tierra tiene
hambre y la gente sale a darle de comer
a través de sus ofrendas durante todo el
mes de agosto se realizan estas ofrendas
en los lugares altos de la ciudad pero
particularmente se ponen más concurridos
estos sitios los días viernes